[Applause]
[Music]
colombia is a country with two faces
unfortunately we all know the bad one
drug lords terrorism and poverty however
there is another much better side
colombia is one of the most stable
economies
in all of latin america for example
colombia has never experienced
hyperinflation
[Music]
and they have the best credit history in
all of latin america
since 1930 the colombian government has
always
paid back its debts
and yes i know none of this is so
spectacular if it weren't for the fact
that we are talking about a latin
american country i mean compared to
venezuela
argentina brazil or even mexico colombia
is not so bad
however all of this has changed with the
coronavirus colombia has been one of the
most affected countries in the world not
only in human terms but also in economic
losses
in this context the government has
raised taxes and this tax increase has
provoked protests and what could have
been a simple protest has ended in real
catastrophe
check it out
[Music]
colombia raises death toll in protests
against president duques to 47
el periodico and here comes the debate
that colombians are having now some say
that the colombian police are ultra
violent
others say that the protesters are
violent even some colombian politicians
like former president alvaro aribe velez
have gone so far as to claim that there
are terrorist groups infiltrating the
protest
so the question that we are asking today
is who is right
why does ivan duque want to raise taxes
and why does the damascus doctrine
play such an important role in this
story today we're going to answer these
questions but first
first i have to tell you about latin
politic many of you have asked us to
talk about latin america more and that
is why that we've launched our own
newsletter
specializing in latin american
geopolitics
for only five dollars a month which is
the price of a big mac menu in bogota
you will receive
three newsletters in your inbox every
week with our analysis on latin american
geopolitics
in latin politics you will discover many
things that are hardly talked about in
the mainstream media for example
you will discover all the details of the
struggle between china and the united
states for brazil's resources
or why russia has so many interests in
argentina in other words
if you subscribe to latin politics you
will not only be supporting
visualpolitik but you also have access
to information that is very difficult to
find in any other media you can find all
the information
at latinpolitik.com and now let's take a
look at some history
[Music]
the hall following the pandemic i'm
going to ask you a question and i'm
going to assume that you are not going
to know how to answer me
how many people pay income tax in
colombia
think about it we're talking about one
of the most populous countries in latin
america they have a population of over
50 million inhabitants
so how many of them pay income tax
well in the year 2020 we are talking
about only 1.6 million people and you'll
say
what really how is that even possible
and in case any of you were wondering no
the answer is not fraud you see most
countries in latin america have two
major problems
poverty and the underground economy to
give you an idea 67
of colombians earn less than 170 usd
per month in addition it is estimated
that 54
of the entire colombian economy is
informal and yes
within this 54 is where all the drug
traffickers that have made this country
sadly infamous would be
[Music]
on top of this we must add political
corruption which takes billions of
dollars every year
as you can imagine given this situation
it is very difficult to collect taxes by
conventional means
[Music]
and you're probably wondering so where
does the colombian state get the money
from well
basically wherever it can since they
cannot tax income colombia has one of
the highest consumption taxes in latin
america almost all consumer products are
taxed at 19
on the other hand colombia also has a
very high corporate tax
extremely high to give you an idea
formal companies can pay up to 71
effective tax on profits and as you can
imagine this is a problem
on the one hand the government of ivan
duque wants to lower corporate taxes to
try to create new economic sectors and
on the other hand
it needs to look for other ways to raise
revenue in other words colombia has had
a fiscal problem for decades
however by all accounts colombia was
able to balance the books
until the pandemic arrived and as has
happened in every country in the world
the coronavirus bill is not cheap
public spending during the pandemic in
colombia amounts to 34.6
trillion pesos semana to give you an
idea those 34.6 trillion pesos are
equivalent to more than 9 billion
and this is just the beginning colombia
is going to have to spend a lot more
money on healthcare and economic
assistance
so where is colombia going to get that
kind of money well mainly by issuing
debt
the problem well here is the problem
colombia's debt is already trading as
though it were junk bloomberg interest
rates on the colombian debt bond
continue to rise
in other words the more money they
borrow the more interest they commit to
pay
so what could the government of even uk
do to avoid all this
well plain and simple collect more taxes
in this way the state will have to ask
for less debts to give you an idea the
government needs to increase its tax
collection
by 6.85 billion dollars which explains
this measure
duque tries to push through new tax
reform in colombia el pais
at this point you're probably wondering
how can taxes be raised in a country
like colombia well duque's plan is based
on three foundations
firstly he wants to lower taxes on
companies in particular
technology companies what he calls the
orange economy this is quite logical in
terms of economic growth but isn't uk
supposed to be
increasing tax revenues yes and this is
where the most controversial part comes
in
the second change is that decay wants to
raise taxes on the middle classes until
now
only people earning more than 4.7
million colombian pesos
which is about 1 200 us dollars a month
they paid income tax well with this
reform you would start paying income tax
from 2.3 million pesos and that's about
600 u.s
but his plan is to booth government
coffers has a third change as i
mentioned colombia has some of the
highest consumption taxes in latin
america however there are a lot of
products that have reductions well now
duquesne wants to raise almost all of
them for example computers had a reduced
tax
and now that would go up to a general
rate of 19 basic products such as milk
or eggs
which previously tax free would now be
taxed at five percent and this is where
the big controversy comes
in because almost all these taxes affect
mainly the middle and the lower classes
and this is what has provoked the first
protests so
what happened next well we're going to
take a look at that right now
[Music]
an erroneous debate it does not matter
whether decay's tax reform was good or
bad after the first protests
the government withdrew it check it out
[Music]
gives in to protests and withdraws
colombia's tax reform el pais
that's right the government has listened
to the protesters and has proposed a
dialogue with the main unions to come up
with a different tax reform however
at the time of making this video
colombia was still having protests
and why are they protesting now you may
ask part of the reason is that these
unions only represent a minority of the
protesters but the main reason is this
[Applause]
colombia raises death troll and protests
against president duques to 47
el periodico yes that's right at the
time of making this video there were
over 47 civilians killed by the police
and 800 wounded the colombian riot
police the dreaded s-man
e-s-m-a-d have even tortured many of the
protesters but
wait a minute as you can imagine all
this violence by the police has not come
out of nowhere
this story is not as simple as evil
police against poor peaceful protesters
listen up
[Applause]
two dead and almost 100 police officers
injured in protests in colombia over tax
reform
abc i mentioned earlier that colombia
has two faces and this story also has
two
sides on the one hand it is undeniable
that colombia has a police brutality
problem to give you an idea
riot police use weapons like this one to
repress demonstrations
what you're looking at is the so-called
venom a non-lethal rocket launcher for
protests
in other words it's a weapon designed to
stop demonstrators without killing them
so what's the problem the problem is
that the missiles are designed to be
launched parabolically that is
an arc however there have been several
reported cases where police have
used the device to shoot directly at
civilians and in these cases the venom
can be lethal so you're probably
wondering but
why are the colombian police so violent
and this is where we get to the really
interesting part of this video it may
surprise you but there are more
colombians with guns than there are
colombians paying income tax
according to the ideas for peace
foundation almost five million
colombians have illegal firearms all
this is the consequence of living in one
of the most violent countries in the
world and we're not only talking about
drug traffickers but also about
terrorist groups such as farc
farc and the national liberation army
and countless paramilitary groups
in fact many people say that there are
infiltrators from these groups amongst
the demonstrators
so are they right at this point in time
we cannot confirm anything but it is not
a completely far-fetched theory
terrorist groups do not disappear
overnight and it is more than reasonable
to think that some of these members of
these groups
may have joined the protests with
weapons all of this explains why the
colombian police force is more like an
army than a normal police force and i'm
not exaggerating at all you see in
almost every country in the world
the police are part of the ministry of
the interior in colombia
however they are in the ministry of
defense in other words the army and the
police are much more united in this
country than
in any other and all this explains new
stories like this
[Music]
more than one thousand men of the
military forces and the army will arrive
to reinforce security
in cali samana and it is at this point
where we can enter the eternal debate of
who is right
the police and the army or protesters
and the answer is
neither think about it the role of the
police is to protect
citizens that is protect the good guys
and stop the bad guys in this case
we're seeing the opposite the violent
ones are still on the streets making
colombia one of the most dangerous
countries in the world however many
innocent people go to jail
suffer torture and even die all this has
a name a name that generates few
headlines
and would rarely become a trending topic
on twitter no it is neither killer
police or
sos colombia the most fitting name is
bad management
yes the colombian police and army needs
to modernize
so why don't they do it well we're going
to look at that right now
[Music]
the damascus doctrine as we've said in
colombia the police and the army go hand
in hand so
what is the colombian army like well
we're talking about an army specialized
in only one thing
special operations that's right after
years of guerrilla warfare in the jungle
the colombian army is expertly skilled
in jungle operations
for example the jungle commandos are
specialists in finding drug traffickers
lost in the jungle so what's the problem
an army has to be able to do more for
example
nato has been trying to collaborate with
the colombian army in international
operations for years but colombia is not
yet ready for that
and that's how in 2011 this strategy
came out
colombia abandons cold war military
doctrine gets ready for 21st century
colombia reports
let me introduce you to the damascus
doctrine you've probably never heard of
it
even if you live in colombia but the
damascus doctrine was colombia's attempt
to modernize its military and what is a
military doctrine you may ask a military
doctrine is the set of manuals processes
strategies and tactics that
guide an army
in other words a modern army such as
that of the united states or israel does
not make decisions on the spur of the
moment
it is standardized in manuals and
protocols in this way
all units can agree if you look at a
military doctrine manual you will find
that everything is explained down to the
smallest detail for example you can see
how a fighter plane has to move to shoot
a specific target
so what does all this have to do with
the protests well a lot
because the damascus doctrine is not
only designed for conventional warfare
but also for civil protection
[Music]
specifically it includes a whole
protocol called unified action
this protocol perfectly illustrates how
the police riot police and the army can
agree it perfectly outlines how violent
groups in a demonstration can be
detected without attacking peaceful
demonstrators
it even explains in detail how to train
soldiers to avoid human
rights violations in other words how to
avoid improvisation in a risky situation
think about it like this
put yourself in the shoes of a policeman
for a moment you're in the middle of a
demonstration where there are armed
people how would you react if you were
in such a situation
well if you've been well trained you
should have a clear action protocol you
should know what you have to do
at that moment in order to not end up
choosing between dying or killing
and i know what you are probably
thinking so why hasn't this damascus
doctrine been useful in avoiding the
ultra violence in the protests in
colombia well pay attention
[Music]
general zapaterio was sworn in as army
commander despite scandal
vanguardia in december 2019 colombia
appointed
a new army chief general zaptero and
this is the man who is responsible for
bringing the whole process of
modernization of the colombian army to a
halt and this is where we come to the
really important debate
in colombia on the one hand we have a
sector of the army that wants to
modernize with military strategies and
doctrines that could be approved by nato
and on the other hand
we have the more traditional sector that
does not want to make the slightest bit
of change
that sector would be headed by general
zapatero so
what's the result colombia continues to
have an army and a police force that is
not prepared to handle protests and all
this means that
what could have been a simple protest
has turned into an urban war
a war that has put the government on the
ropes
so now the question is over to you do
you think that we could have seen a
different situation
if the army had kept the damascus
doctrine and more importantly
how can colombia solve its fiscal
problem you can leave me your answers
in the comments below and as always
don't forget that on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week
so subscribe to this channel and hit the
little bell icon so you don't miss any
of our updates
and if you liked this video like it and
i'll see you in the next one all the
best see you soon
you